hello everyone my name's Damien I'm one
of the designers on The Witcher world
hunt and today we're going to continue a
lessons on how to be a professional
witch in the hearts of stone expansion
you will embark on a new adventure full
of mystery danger and of course romance
here we'll explore new gear tactics and
enhancements that will help you on the
path runes and glyphs runes are placed
in weapons with open slots adding a
bonus to your attacks such as dagger
burning or bleeding glyphs are placed in
armor with open slots providing bonuses
such as increased to sign intensity or
even vitality regeneration in novigrad
speak with the rune write the world's
never ending creation be praised crowd
something for me would you for a
substantial investment this vendor
offers powerful new enchantments for
your gear rune words can be applied to
weapons while glyph words can be applied
to your chest armor with at least three
rune slots
thanks to runes and glyphs you can have
even more fun in you game plus these
upgrades will give you increased power
and more abilities making your journey
even more enjoyable the new moon armor
set is perfect for a thief in the night
or a suave entrepreneur this medium
armor collection features an 80%
increase to critical hit damage and 25%
bonus to gold what seems to be the
problem
embrace undeclared income I get how that
might have happened be glad to clear
them up and check your armor to avert
any incoming arrows with the glyph word
deflection the rune words elation causes
fatal blows to further increase your
adrenaline points
plication causes vitality stamina and
toxicity to regenerate faster once your
adrenaline points reach their maximum
but at the cost of your adrenaline
points slowly decreasing the Akira Gaia
is a light armor set featuring for us
50% resistance to bludgeoning and
slashing damage along with a significant
increase to which assign intensity the
affero steel saber features a 75% bonus
to critical hit damage and an increase
to ignite odd and access sign intensity
enhanced a stylish set with the root
word rejuvenation causing all fatal
blows to restore 25% stamina a blade and
chanted with replenishment uses an
adrenaline point when you cast the sign
and your next attack will be charged
with that same sign
my favorite the glyph word eruption
causes enemies on fire from Agni to
explode upon death and set fire to
others
the school of the Viper this media
marmoset grants immunity to poison and a
60% increased damage resistance from
elementals and monsters the blades of
the Viper features a 75% bonus to
critical hit damage and a 15% chance to
poison equipped poison blades and
fixative allowing a blade covered in oil
if permanent 50% chance of poisoning the
target and peach-pit use frenzy to
easily dodge an enemy's counter-attack
be full of surprises with side effects
allowing you to imbibe a second random
portion with that additional toxicity
cost the glyph word retribution gives a
30% chance of returning some damage to
the attacker when at full health
the rune word invigoration turns excess
vitality regeneration into increased
damage on your next hit prolongation
causes unblocked blows to increase
portion duration by half a second
decoctions are an alchemical product
akin to portions they offer unique
advantages at the cost of increased
toxicity use the kinder decoction to
regenerate vitality in stamina is
consumed restore vitality when Dilek
damage with the a chimera decoction
hearts of stone introduces four new
leader cards for the monster Skrtel
northern realms end of Guardian decks
plus one new scourge card for the sky
tell and the monster deck as well as for
neutrals including my favorite of course
the cow now let's take a look at a grand
match our monster deck contains 29
unique cards including nine heroes for a
total strength of 176 plus two special
cards our leader erred in the
treacherous double the strength of all
spies played on the board let's look at
a hand so we have cards with muster
morale boost few hero cards now we could
trade up to two cards and hopefully find
a vampire master card that would bring
all of the others on the board but let's
not chance that let's stick with what we
have our opponent chooses to go first
let's choose a meal for 5 attack that
should protect us against scorch his
card is higher than ours our opponent
uses mysterious elf which is a spy card
that will draw two cards to the player's
hand
I'm going to use full tell for another
five points she uses commanders Hall
doubling the Rose attack power let's use
all given Africa one of the new cards in
house of stone now he can be placed in a
Mele or in the range rule and give +1 to
all other unit cards in the row she
plays she rue which is a score tells
each card with portability luckily I
don't have any siege cards on the board
so let's use our fire elemental card so
the score tell uses 810 hero card your
vet let's further buffer cards on the
front line with the Karen that brings us
to a total of 35 points but we still
behind our opponent in terms of cards
Scott L plays Nova for them animal role
boost but remember hero cards are immune
to special abilities and that includes
buffs all right so it's not looking good
we're behind in points and in cards as
well the decoy can swap a cards on the
battlefield to return it to my hand I'd
love to do it on that spy unfortunately
it's a hero so I can't do that what I'm
gonna do instead is bring back all gear
and save him maybe for the next round
our opponent uses one of the decoys to
bring in the frontline reducing the
attack by 12 alright so right now we
have a shot to overtax kotel let's use
Triss Merigold to take the lead our
opponent down by 5 points with a 2 card
late decides pass that's fine
we have delete no reason to play any
more cards so let's just pass and take
round one
firk of monster deck is that one random
card will stay on the board into the
next round so instead of four cards in
play I actually have five I have one on
the board so let's choose the hero card
lesson to stop with a strong lead Skrtel
uses have a cost smuggler with muster
which instantly fetches the other cards
and that ties us up at 15 so let's use
your faith bringing our attack to 25
which is only a 10-point lead right now
Scott L uses villain for seven and
close-combat Scotch so we lose a mia it
is safer right now to play the Erica's
card muster will instantly play the
remaining Erica's cards in our deck or
hands put them onto the board Scott L
uses havoc our healer so the medic will
bring back a card from the player's
discard pile and she decided to bring
back Melvin so we have one card left
good old old gear so let's choose them
on the frontline and buff Erika's trio
for a total of 41 our opponent plays
Berkeley for six that hurts / whistling
the lead score it's opacity is 41 40 we
take the round and win the match good
game with new gear powerful enchantments
and a few gwen tricks up your sleeve you
are ready for a new adventure good luck
as you continue on the path of The
Witcher
you